تحياتي لك السيده ميسون تحياتي للساده
المشاهدين الكرام نعم لا شك ان قوافل
المساعدات الانسانيه ما زالت تتجه صوبه
معبر باب الهوى خلفي بهذا الاتجاه قادمه
من مدينه انطاكيا بهذا الاتجاه الاخر الان
يعني دخلت قبل قليل هنالك مجموعه من
الشاحنات وعادت ايضا الشاحنات اخرى من
المعبر بعد ان افرغت حملاتها وقبل قليل
وصلني الاتي
وصول قافله مساعدات قطريه الى معبر باب
الهوى لاغاثه لاغاثه المنكوبين جراء
الزلزال الذي ضرب شمال سوريا القافله
مكونه من سبعه شاحنات وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
عن جسرا بريا بدا اليوم يعمل عليه بشكل
واضح نتيجه لاصلاح الطرق البريه بالدرجه
الاولى رح نتحدث عن طريق الواصل ما بين
مدينه الريحانيه وكذلك ايضا مدينه انطاكيا
هذا الطريق الذي تضرر قرابه 2 كيلو متر
ذهابا وايابا اليوم عمل على انجاز الجهه
اليسرى من هذا الطريق اثناء خروجهم والان
مرت قبل قليل من يميني هذه الشاحنه التي
عادت من معبر باب الهوى اتجاه الحدود
السوريه التركيه
يؤكد ان هذا الطريق الذي فتح ربما قد يخفف
عن هؤلاء الذين يتواجدون في داخل السوري
لا سيما ان المساعدات الانسانيه جاءت في
مختلف المستويات هنالك مساعدات في مجال
الاغاثه وكذلك ايضا في مجال اخر وهو نتحدث
عنه مجال الضحايا الزلازل وبالتالي نحن
نتحدث عن مسارات مفتوحه اليوم جسور البريه
والجويه تعمل بشكل وانسيابيه كبيره نظرا
لاصلاح مطار غازي عنتاب بالدرجه الاولى
ومن ثم اصلاح المطار الاخر هنا مطار مطار
هاتاي